Off.
Il y a des millénaires.
Une figure légendaire énonça 5 commandements
divins, desquels, affirma-t-il, toute autre
vérité devra être déduite.
Et pendant des siècles et des siècles, des
générations de savants allaient en effet
déduire des livres et des livres de savoir
de ces 5 commandements.
Sauf que...
Sauf que ces 5 commandements, appelés axiomes
d’Euclide, ne sont pas si évidents.
En fait, ils sont contredits… par mon caleçon
!
Off.
En particulier, le 5ème axiome d’Euclide
dit que si on prend une droite verte et un
point bleu, alors il existe une et une seule
droite bleue, parallèle à la droite verte
et passant par le point bleu.
Des grands mathématiciens comme Bertrand
trouvaient cet axiome si évident qu’ils
ont essayé de le déduire des 4 autres axiomes.
En vain.
Et pour cause.
Sur mon caleçon, le 5ème axiome d’Euclide
est
en fait faux.
En effet, par ce point, je peux tracer deux
droites distinctes qui n’intersecteront
pas une troisième droite.
Et ça, c’est parce que les droites du caleçon
semblent vouloir s’éloigner les unes des
autres.
Off.
En fait, dans la vidéo précédente, on a
déjà vu un exemple de géométrie dans laquelle
le 5ème axiome d’Euclide est faux.
Vous vous souvenez ? Sur la sphère, deux
droites ne sont jamais parallèles.
Ces droites semblent vouloir se rapprocher
l’une de l’autre.
Du coup, elles s’y intersectent toujours
à deux lieus antipodaux.
La géométrie de mon caleçon est donc un
peu l’opposé de la géométrie sphérique.
On dit que mon caleçon a une géométrie
de courbure négative, ou géométrie hyperbolique.
Enfin presque.
Mon caleçon n’est pas un très bon exemple
de géométrie hyperpolique car il n’est
pas hyperbolique partout.
En fait, certains endroits sont même à courbure
positive, comme la sphère.
Off.
Au début du 19ème siècle, certains génies
comme Gauss, Bolyai et Lobatchevski ont imaginé
l’existence de la géométrie hyperbolique.
Mais leur géométrie hyperbolique semblait
vivre dans un monde abstrait, irréel, intangible.
Ils furent incapables de prendre un point
de vue extrinsèque.
Et pourtant, la Nature y était arrivée ! En
effet, certains coraux ont une surface hyperbolique.
Puis, plus tard, les artistes y sont arrivés
eux aussi.
Je vous invite d’ailleurs à regarder ce
Ted Talk à ce sujet.
Vous pouvez voir que la surface hyperbolique
construite s’entortille, et semble ainsi
prendre « plus de place » que le plan euclidien.
Off.
Pour rendre la surface hyperbolique plus tangible,
il est utile de s’imaginer vivre à l’intérieure
de la surface hyperbolique.
Imaginons-nous par exemple jouer au golf sur
la surface hyperbolique.
Lorsque l’on tape un swing, la balle de
golf va suivre une ligne droite.
Mais comme la surface est hyperbolique, cette
ligne droite va sembler s’éloigner de la
ligne droite entre nous et le trou de la balle
de golf.
En fait, si la courbure de la surface hyperbolique
est plus grande que la distance qui nous sépare
du trou, il y aura alors de grande chance
que la trajectoire de la balle de golf s’éloigne
tellement vite du trou que l’on se retrouve
plus éloigné du trou après le swing, même
si on a tapé la balle avec la bonne puissance,
et avec une toute petite erreur angulaire.
En fait, si vous avez un jour la chance de
jouer au golf sur une surface très hyperbolique,
je vous conseille d’y aller par petits accoups.
Ne tentez pas le hole-in-one.
Vous risqueriez de le regretter.
Off.
Intuitivement, la raison pour laquelle vous
avez de bonnes chances de vous éloigner en
tapant la balle avec la bonne puissance, c’est
parce qu’il y a « beaucoup d’espace » loin
de vous, dans un espace hyperbolique.
Une façon de mathématiser ceci consiste
à remarquer qu’un cercle de rayon R a une
plus grande circonférence sur la surface
hyperbolique que dans le plan euclidien.
Le rayon R d’un cercle en géométrie hyperbolique
est donc supérieure à Tau*R, où Tau est
la fameuse constante fondamentale que certains
appellent 2 π.
Tout ceci peut sembler encore difficile à
concevoir.
Plutôt que de chercher à avoir un point
de vue extrinsèque, ou un point de vue intrinsèque,
on peut explorer un troisième point de vue,
dont on a déjà parlé dans la vidéo précédente.
À savoir, n’y aurait-il pas une bonne carte
de la surface hyperbolique ?
Off.
Ma carte préférée de la géométrie hyperbolique
est le disque de Poincaré.
Le disque de Poincaré est un peu l’inverse
de la carte de Mercator.
Au lieu d’agrandir les pays sur le bord
de l’image, le disque de Poincaré les rétrécit.
C’est ce qu’explique Étienne Ghys dans
ce magnifique exposé.
[...] D’ailleurs, un bonhomme qui se rapproche
du bord du disque de Poincaré rétrécit
si vite que ses pas rétrécissent beaucoup
ici, si bien qu’il ne pourra jamais atteindre
le bord du disque de Poincaré en un nombre
fini de pas.
Contrairement à ce que suggère le disque
de Poincaré, la surface hyperbolique est
infinie !
Par ailleurs, alors que les droites de la
géométrie sphérique tracée sur la Mercator
semblent s’incurver vers l’intérieur,
les droites de la géométrie hyperbolique
tracée sur le disque de Poincaré semblent
s’incurver vers l’extérieur.
En fait, dans le disque de Poincaré, ces
droites sont représentées par des arcs de
cercles perpendiculaires à la frontière
du disque.
Off.
Le disque de Poincaré a aussi le bon goût
d’être une carte conforme de la surface
hyperbolique, ce qui veut dire que les angles
dans le disque sont les vrais angles de la
géométrie hyperbolique.
En particulier, on voit très bien sur le
disque de Poincaré pourquoi la somme des
angles d’un triangle en géométrie hyperbolique
est toujours inférieure à 180°.
Mieux encore, il existe en géométrie hyperbolique
des triangles « à l’infini », dont les
angles sont tous nuls ! Encore plus fou, ces
triangles dont les périmètres sont infinis
ont une
aire finie !
Un autre truc absolument génial avec la géométrie
hyperbolique est qu’elle possède bien plus
de symétries que la géométrie euclidienne.
Off.
Alors qu’il n’existe en gros qu’un nombre
fini de façon de paver un plan euclidien,
il existe un nombre infini de façons de paver
la surface hyperbolique.
Et chaque pavage de la géométrie hyperbolique
donne lieu à des images toutes plus incroyables
les unes que les autres !
N’est-ce pas incroyable qu’une telle géométrie
existe ? De nos jours, on sait qu’elle se
retrouve dans plein d’applications, et même
dans la Nature.
Mais à l’époque où Bolyai l’a découverte,
il pensait qu’il avait ainsi créé un univers
qui n’a pas d’équivalent dans le réel.
Ainsi se sentant emporté
par
un élan divin, il affirma : « À partir
du néant, j’ai créé un nouveau monde.
»